موجه غضب واسعه تواجهها اليسا في السوشيال
ميديا
والسبب غنائها مؤخرا من اول دقيقه الاغنيه
الشهيره التي جمعتها مع المغني المغربي
سعد المجرد المحكوم عليه بالسجن ست سنوات
اليسا عرضت فيديو كليب الاغنيه على شاشه
كبيره في حفله لها بجمهوريه الدومينيكان
الامر الذي تسبب في جدل واسع وهجوم على
الفنانه اللبنانيه
منتقدوها اعتبروا تصرفها زاما لسعد المتهم
بالاغتصاب واتهموها بالسقوط في التناقص في
تصرفاتها بين حديثها الدائم عن زعمها
للمراه ومناصرتها لقضاياها وبين تجاهلها
لما حدث مع المجرد
في المقابل الاخرون دافعوا عن اليسا
قائلين انها تحافظ على اصول المهنه بدعمها
لزميرها ان كان ظالما او مظلوما بل وذهب
البعض الاخر لمدحها واعتبار موقفها بطوليه
شاركونا ارائكم في التعليقات ما رايكم
انتم في تصرف اليسا
[موسيقى]